NECA is so Bittersweet to be chatting
with you today how are you feeling after
last night's episode
I'm good I am better than I thought I
would be
um there's actually a lot of relief
um uh Wednesdays you know will be
Bittersweet but
um I thought it was a great episode too
I couldn't have asked for better
absolutely and I want to go back to the
end of the episode Tribal Council Jeff
was asking everyone how confident they
were about how it was going to play out
and you were very confident but what did
you think was gonna happen did you think
you were going to be the one who got
their torch snuffed
no I did not think I was going to be the
one who would get my torch snuffed
um but hey I was
99.5 out of 10 that I got my smart snap
but no
um my tribe had you know my alliance has
showed himself loyal and
um you know when I made that comment I
believe that they were going to stay
true again
who were they telling you that they were
going to be voting out
Noel Noel okay yeah makes sense but did
that shock you then because I feel like
you were really close with Jesse really
close with code you guys were like a
trio I mean like Jesse even said that he
looked at you as a mother figure on this
show like do you feel betrayed by them
at all
um I understand why they did that
um with you know
you know knowing that hey we had a like
if the tides were the tables were turned
would I have done that because you know
I would not but I also understand that
that's the game you know it was up to me
to find out that
um you know it's not always what it
seems you know in the game of Survivor
um yes with
um Jesse you know even though he saw me
and kind of compared me with his mother
which I thought was the greatest honor
um and with you know the relationships I
had recorded I also kind of understand
why things played out the way they did
yes we had an agreement to vote Noel you
know whenever that was made you know I
remember thinking like this is too easy
you know but
um at that point I did not have any
reason why
um I should go tell them I don't you
know go challenge that
absolutely and you know those challenges
I have to ask you they look exhausting
but how hard are they as a Survivor fan
I need to know because they look
they maybe they look a little bit easier
but I know they're challenging I need to
know
those challenges are worse in real life
they're easier to look at on TV you know
I you know I was gonna explain that to
my family I'm like the
um
that the platforms or even like the last
The Challenge from the last episode or
the first the the very first
um episode The Challenge that we had
going up those boards like those things
are a whole lot more intimidating in
real life than they looked on TV and
when you it's one thing when you look at
something on TV saying I think I can do
this but when you're taking the fact
that you've been sleeping on bamboo you
haven't slept for five days you haven't
eaten anything except coconut you know
on coconut water for those five days
like it takes a toll on your body and
what you would have been able to do
maybe on a good day it you're bringing a
whole lot less to the table when it
comes to it yeah absolutely I feel like
people kind of forget about that when
they're watching it on TV so that's
super interesting as a Survivor fan I
love hearing that now I just want to
like kind of get your thoughts on this
you know the past three people that have
gone have all been women like where do
you see what do you see is the future
for the women on this season
or what do you hope um
yeah the the a lot of when we think of
the conversations that we had around
this was keeping the tribes strong and
keeping the tribes strong boring
relations with physical strength
meanwhile you know strength we know that
there are different kinds of strength
and stretch shows up in various ways
um the way the challenges are physical
strength those coming to play that kind
of Pander to that
um so you know it's yes it's a it's
three women have gone you know first one
two three have been women because you
know the the tribe has been focused on
keeping the tribe strong physically
absolutely totally makes sense now
looking back even at last night's
episode and previous episodes who do you
think is kind of either running your
tribe or running the game right now
um as far as Bessie is concerned
um I think Jess is running the tribe I
knew that while we were out there I
still
um stick to that narrative after
watching three episodes
um you know I know like our first driver
Council you know
um it was like oh this neck and Cody and
then you know Justine and Noel and then
it seemed like Jesse and white were kind
of floating you know and then they were
like hey why don't we have our Island
marriage you know but
um you know at that point I remember
looking around and you know kind of like
being impressed with how well you know
Jesse was building relationships with
everyone under on the tribe or even
within an alliance I knew he had a lot
of influence on Cody as well even though
it seemed like oh Cody and I were closer
yeah absolutely Justine said the same
thing last week she also said kind of
Jesse is kind of behind the scenes like
pulling the strings a little bit but no
one really sees that because Cody is so
out there and jumping off cliffs and
doing all those things so that's super
interesting now just to like after
watching it and reflecting and being
there was the game of Survivor in your
journey on the show everything you hoped
it would be
it was more than all I hoped it would be
I was blown away
um I have so much respect for the show
I'm just getting there really seeing
what it takes to bring a show like that
to life I did not understand the scale
of what went into it or the scope of all
that went into it to bring it to life I
had so much respect living there but
then also just coming back realizing all
that happens and when you look at
content that they have it's literally
like
creating a storyline keeping it going
telling that story excellently with one
percent of contents you know you know I
think they do a fantastic job and I
could not like I am grateful to have had
this experience and um to get to be part
of the survival family legit absolutely
legit there you go well we loved
watching you on screen I love that you
were able to share your stories they
were so powerful and meaningful so thank
you for doing that you also look
beautiful today I love the look
um but yeah love it all right well thank
you so much for chatting with me and
enjoy the rest of the season thank you
so much have a good day you too